que anne marie guillemard sociologue
professeur émérite à l'université paris
descartes anne marie guillemard bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
alors on en parlait la commission
spéciale retraites à l'assemblée a donc
mis un terme à ses travaux sur le volet
principal de la réforme mardi soir sans
avoir pu achever son examen
l'opposition parle d'un fiasco
parlementaire et gouvernementale quelle
est votre regard sur cette situation le
gouvernement est il dû aller au bout de
cet examen
je pense que il ya un problème de
démographie de démocratie manifeste est
en fait qu'est-ce que c'est cette
réforme des retraites
elle ne ressemble plus du tout à celle
qui était prévue par le candidat
maquereau en 2017
j'ai eu effectivement beaucoup
d'évolutions mlc c'est pas des
révolutions c'est radicalement opposées
un exemple ça devait être une retraite
une réforme qui se faisait à coût
constant
on ne parlait pour une fois on ne
parlait pas d' équilibre de mme nacéra
on voulait faire une réforme qui était
pensé pour le 21e siècle c'est à dire
avec une grande mobilité professionnelle
ont fait plusieurs métiers dans la vie
et l'idée que sept devaient être rendre
transparent pour les individus pour
qu'ils puissent choisir le moment
opportun pour prendre leur retraite
mais qu'est ce qui reste de ça il reste
que des préoccupations financières des
kilims c'est à dire qu'on est revenu au
cette réforme précédente qui toutes
parts et et des réformes paramétriques
donc hallyday soit en bouche le curseur
de l'âge soit en bouge le curseur de la
durée d'activité où on bouge les deux
mais toutes les réformes ont fait ça et
est donc où est ce qu'elle est en forme
de 2017 jeu
c'est pas mal n'est plus là et pourtant
le président emmanuel macron demande à
ses députés de continuer à vendre cette
réforme
quand vous le comprenez pas bien sauf si
cette réforme initialement annoncé comme
l'adaptation de notre système de
retraite au 21ème siècle plus d'égalité
plus de choix plus de transparence était
en fait une question derrière de de
désengagement de l'état
c'est ce à quoi ça ressemble aujourd'hui
ce que je peux observer c'est qu'on ne
parle plus que de 2 de finance de coûts
des retraites alors que c'était
justement quelque chose à pois du pib
constant et l'un de vos interlocuteurs
tout à l'heure la rappeler là ce qu'on
voit dans l'étude d'impact
c'est précisément une contraction du du
du taux de pib du pourcentage de pib
consacré aux retraites on va passer de
14 % ce qui était à coût constant
affiché par le conseil d'orientation des
retraites à 12.8 enfin bon à l'horizon
2050 donc on voit bien qu'à une
trajectoire de baisse et que peut-être
c'était ça qu'il y avait derrière cette
ce beau projet de réforme qu'on nous a
vendu comme quelque chose d'innovant
et je dois dire que moi même j'y
adhérais mais que là si c'est une
affaire de de désengagement de l'état
parce que c'est ça qu'il semble rien
n'est dit là dessus mais mais quand même
on s'aperçoit que le régime universel va
permettre à l'état de passer pour la
cotisation des fonctionnaires
d'un taux de 70% puisque c'est pas
provisionner les retraites des
fonctionnaires à un taux aligné sur
celui du patronat du prieuré 16% et perd
rien n'est dit sur cette économie
extraordinaire est-ce que ça va
permettre d'augmenter le salaire des
enseignants pour qu'ils ne perdent pas
trop rien on ne sait rien donc du flou
en tout cas pour revenir à la
l'opposition à la façon de s'opposer à
ce projet de l'opposition la stratégie
de la france insoumise et c'est 19000
plus de 19000 avant amendement est ce
qu'au fond s ne sert pas plus le
gouvernement puisque résultat des
courses c'est le projet initial qui sera
présentée qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette je pense que de toute façon c'est
dé la question des retraites est une
question de société c'est une question
importante et là on a un déni de
démocratie on peut pas discuter et que
qui est des amendements est ce que la
révolution a dû aller au bout selon vous
terminer le travail et je ne sais pas
parce que c'est comme c'est plus la
réforme qui était prévu et qu'on ne sait
pas on va dire l'étude d'impact qui
était une obligation maintenant pour
pour des textes eni s'est mis à faire
elle c'est 1000 pages mais en fait il y
en a que 90 qui sont sur le sujet
c'est-à-dire exposé les motifs et
quelles conséquences chiffrées à quel
impact et c'est là où on est dans le
flou total
parce que cet âge pivot qui est sorti
deux comme ça au dernier moment qui
n'était pas dans la réforme initial il
faut voir qu'en termes d'impact c'est
très grave
on va demander aux aux ouvriers parce
que ce sont eux qui ont à 62 ans la
durée d'activité nécessaire pour avoir
une retraite pleine
on va leur demander d'allonger à 64
sinon pénalité écoutez réforme juste en
ouvrant une retraite qui est plus
équitable et moi je vois pas où est
l'équité
franchement en tout cas prochain acte
lundi prochain est ce que le fameux 49,3
à savoir un passage en force du
gouvernement
est-ce qu'on s'y rapproche selon vous un
jeu peut pas dire non je ne sais pas ce
serait encore un deuxième déni de
démocratie de discussion démocratique
sur un texte tellement important pour
tous les français je suis un peu étonné
parce que quand on a le conseil d'état
qui dit c'est pas on risque donc d'être
non constitutionnelle à la fin
qu'ensuite il ya toute cette opposition
sur quoi 20 qu'elle ait l'appui de cette
réforme jumelles au sein de l air m
on n'est pas justement les avocats
tiennent bon reste toujours autant
déterminer les experts comptables
maintenant toujours plus de contestation
dont vous parliez de l'avis du conseil
d'état est ce que le gouvernement va
pouvoir tenir finalement face à tout à
cette opposition massive
je n'en ai pas idée je ne comprends pas
parce que manifestement c'est une
réforme mal ficelée va telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui mal ficelé bâclé on a plein
d'inconnues il faudrait qu'on ait évoqué
la valeur du point
mais enfin c'est dans un régime par
points la valeur du point est central
personne ne sait rien sur la valeur du
point effectivement il ya eu une
nouvelle annonce
mais l'indicateur cette valeur du point
resterait à créer puisque l'insee
indiqué ne pas avoir été saisi
formellement d'une demande de création
d'un tel nom indicateurs
donc on est dans l'à peu près mais moi
je reconnais pas la france on a on a une
fonction publique des hauts
fonctionnaires des statistiques et là
tout va tous les économistes ce qui
était comme antoine bozio qu'ils étaient
favorables qui ont porté cette réforme
en 2010 700 sont frappés et 10 mais ça
n'a pas de sens
il n'y a pas de de transparence il ya
pas de démocratie enfin il n'y a pas
cette étude d'impact et mal ficelé
elle laisse plein d'inconnues et on
demande de donner un blanc-seing en
quelque sorte pour terminer hier le
président emmanuel macron s'est adressé
à ses députés et lords il aura 10 1
continuer d'être fier d'être des
amateurs alors c'est quoi on est face à
des amateurs finalement qui font un
projet de loi mais c'est pas les députés
qui sont les amateurs l'avs
c'est vraiment l'exécutif enfin d'apport
ce revirement pack dernier avec edouard
philippe
sortant des réformes paramétriques qui
n'avait jamais été dans le projet
initial
c'est un peu étrange et puis maintenant
on est dans l'improvisation et on ne
peut pas s'empêcher de penser qu' il y
avait une question effectivement de
désengager l'état financièrement et que
la manip c'était ça et et tout le reste
et de l'habillage
merci beaucoup anne marie guillemard
d'avoir partagé votre analyse sur notre
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
sociologue professeur émérite à
l'université paris descartes